benjamin lucas coordinateur national de
génération prouesse benjamins lucas
bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation dans la matinale de rtl
france alors pour commencer vous propose
un point sur la situation sanitaire un
nouveau conseil de défense sanitaire
attendu ce matin avec cette volonté
affichée hier du ministre de la santé
concernant la levée des restrictions
regardez je suis ouvert à l'idée d'une
approche territoire par territoire dans
la levée des mesures de freinage comme
j'y étais favorable lors de leur mise en
place
ah vous êtes favorable à ce type de
stratégie
oui moi je crois qu'il faut être très
prudent faire très attention parce qu'on
ne peut pas prendre le risque d'une
nouvelle flambée
d'ailleurs on n'est toujours pas sorti
aujourd'hui de 7 de cette vague
pandémique terrible donc je crois qu'une
approche territoriale une approche qui
tient compte des situations sur un
territoire aussi vaste que le nôtre me
paraît très pertinente et d'ailleurs
nous le disons depuis le début de cette
crise alors marine le pen aviaire s'est
dit opposé à l'ouverture des classes
pour les primaires il rentre dès lundi
prochain à au vu de la situation
sanitaire fragile à ce que la question
doit effectivement se poser aujourd'hui
je crois que le gouvernement a échoué
sur la question de la pandémie à l'école
il a échoué sur le plan sanitaire on a
vu que les contaminations dans les
classes étaient énormes il a mis en
danger les personnels éducatifs d'un
point de vue sanitaire il a mis en
danger les élèves leurs familles et il a
échoué sur un plan éducatif puisque on a
dû fermer puisque l'école de la
république ne veut pas se dérouler dans
de bonnes conditions malgré les
préconisations malgré les avis mail
les conseils des personnels éducatifs
qui sont les premiers concernés mais moi
je crois que il faut que les enfants
puissent aller à l'école dans les
meilleures conditions possibles ce que
je regrette une fois de plus sur ce
sujet c'est que on prend des mesures une
fois qu'on est au pied du mur et puis
après on n'anticipe rien ou si peu pour
trouver de bonnes solutions c'est un peu
ça je crois je crois le drame
aujourd'hui sur l'école et ça montre une
incompétence finalement du ministre
blanquet 79% des français pour 79 des
français les persos professeurs et des
personnels de l'enseignement doivent
être vaccinés en priorité selon un
sondage opinionway publié aujourd'hui
c'est effectivement une priorité qu on
aurait pu finalement anticipé
bien sûr si on considère et c'est mon
cas qu'il est essentiel que les enfants
de la république puissent aller à
l'école
puisqu'il ya à prendre puis se partager
les savoir si on considère qu'il est
essentiel que la l'école a un rôle dans
la république et centrale et que la
pandémie ne doit pas considérablement
l'affaiblir comme lors du du produit
confinement alors il faut que la
stratégie vaccinale
il faut que toute la stratégie sanitaire
soit en adéquation avec cet objectif
éducatif
alors l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe il s'est exprimé il est revenu
sur sa gestion de la crise sanitaire
il a reconnu un manque de nuances et de
prudence et regarder quand vous prenez
10 12 ou 15 décisions par jour vous
savez que vous allez vous planter il
faut accepter l'idée que parfois on
prend des décisions qui sont moins
bonnes que d'autres en situation de
crise
c'est presque mécanique compte tenu du
nombre de décisions que vous prenez
et du fait qu'elles sont souvent fondées
sur des informations incomplètes et
erronées ou contradictoires vous les
entendez vous les comprenez ces
explications de l'ancien premier
ministre
moi je trouve que c'est une forme
d'indécence à parler de soi du tout une
forme d'indécence à faire alors qu'on
n'est toujours pas sortie de cette crise
le récit sur soi même pour des ambitions
peut-être présidentielle de concurrence
avec elles peignaient le maquereau qui
sait moi je crois que si ce pouvoir
emmanuel macron edouard philippe
puis jean castex avait voulu faire moins
d'erreurs et bien il aurait dû ouvrir un
peu plus la voie de la consultation et
changer un peu plus être un peu moins
sûr de lui même un peu moins convaincu
de son hyper puissance et c'est un
problème de la vème république
moi j'appelle depuis plusieurs mois à ce
conte
j'ouvre le conseil de défense à des
représentants de l'opposition
de la même façon puisqu'on nous dit sans
cesse quand on est en guerre ou la même
façon que churchill avait dans son
conseil de guerre
c'est plus fidèle ennemi il est
important que les décisions qui sont
prises ne soient pas dans un conclave
choisi uniquement par le président de la
république et sur son nom plaisir mais
qu'on mette finalement l'intelligence
collective au service de la gestion de
cette crise or là j'ai l'impression on
est souvent dans le calcul dans la
stratégie et même quand des décisions
sont prises moi je les soutiens je
soutiens toujours à priori parce que je
crois qu'il faut faire tout pour
évidemment protéger la santé des
français mais je regrette qu'on ait
encore un un cloisonnement qui
finalement nuit à la recherche de
solutions les plus efficaces possibles
alors la quasi totalité des pouvoirs
exceptionnels accordés au gouvernement
face à l'épidémie
kovy de 19 serait prolongé jusqu'au 31
octobre
selon nos confrères de france inter qui
ont pu avoir accès à un document est ce
que c'est nécessaire la seule chose
qu'on anticipe aujourd'hui c'est le sont
les restrictions de nos libertés des
seules choses que l'on anticipe
aujourd'hui c'est l'exception à l'état
de droit moi c'est cela qui m'inquiète
moi je crois qu'on doit être capable
dans une république comme la nôtre de
gérer en dehors des deux l'exception des
situations aux pandémies qu'on doit être
capable de concilier une protection
sanitaire de nos concitoyens des mesures
qui sont parfois durs et nos concitoyens
et nous les acceptons collectivement
quand même avec beaucoup de patience et
beaucoup de courage depuis depuis un an
un peu plus d'un an maintenant je crois
qu'on doit être capable de le faire dans
le respect de l'état de droit de nos
libertés et je suis inquiet un peu de
cette tentation liberticide et
autoritaire qui qui existe avec ce
pouvoir mais qui ne date pas d'ailleurs
de cette pandémie
alors au début de cette semaine on a un
peu moins parler de la situation
sanitaire on a plus parlé de la question
de sécurité après les propos d'emmanuel
macron hier le premier ministre jean
castex était en déplacement dans le haut
rhin où il s'est engagé sur 15000 places
de prison supplémentaires regarder
j'appelle à refuser l'angélisme du
déterminisme social autant que la
démagogie du tout répressif
alors l'annnonce de ces places de prison
c'est une réponse ajustée selon vous
alors que ces derniers jours la justice
a été jugée trop laxiste notamment on
l'a vu par des policiers en colère comme
c'est surprenant à quelques mois d'une
campagne présidentielle qu'on agite le
chiffon sécuritaire il y a oui
aujourd'hui besoin de protection pour
nos concitoyens il ya besoin de réponses
il ya besoin de police républicaine de
moyens pour cette police de la
république rappelle que les policiers
sont soumis depuis de longs mois un
stress énorme à des burn out qui
explosent à une pression et à des moyens
qui ne sont pas à la hauteur je note en
revanche que sur la question des prisons
c'est complètement atur parce qu'il ya
une corrélation démontré entre
l'augmentation des constructions de
places de prison et l'augmentation des
incarcérations c'est à dire que la
courbe de la surpopulation carcérale ne
baisse pas à mesure qu'on construit ce
qui est un problème c'est que on enferme
peut-être trop qu'on ne pense pas d
alternative à la prison
et donc on peut être dans une course
comme ça sans fin de construction de
construction de construction ce n'est
pas ça qui résout le problème de la
surpopulation carcérale
il faut aujourd'hui une politique
sécuritaire qu'ils soient pragmatiques
qui soit intelligente qui ne soit pas
fondée sur les velléités cynique et
électoraliste des uns ou des autres et
c'est malheureusement ce qui manque
aujourd'hui c'est pouvoir
en tout cas à droite xavier bertrand il
ne s'en cache pas et en campagne pour la
présidentielle
voyez lui ce qu'il promet ch dès
l'automne 2022
je proposerai aux français de modifier
la constitution quand on s'attaque à un
gendarme un policier un pompier ou à un
maire une peine de prison d'un an
minimum doit être automatique
ça c'est une mesure que vous pourriez
soutenir moi je vais vous dire je suis
engagé auprès de karima delli dans les
hauts de france pour que cette région
pour que notre région change de majorité
et qu'on en finisse avec avec monsieur
bertrand bien ce genre de déclaration ne
prouve que nous avons raison de nous
battre nous avons eu raison
unir la gauche et les écologistes parce
que monsieur bertrand qui a été il ya
cinq ans chez nous le rempart à
l'extrême droite lutte aujourd'hui la
courte échelle parce que faire des
déclarations qui pourraient être celles
de madame le pen n'est pas digne n'est
pas digne de l'élu de la république
qu'il est n'est pas digne de celui qui a
été élu pour faire barrage à l'extrême
droite justement il ya cinq ans il est
temps qu'il s'en aille et je le dis aux
électeurs qui comme moi sont qui ont
fait barrage à le pen il y a cinq ans
dans l'autre français qui se sentent
aujourd'hui trahis déçu parlera par
l'attitude de monsieur bertrand et par
sa sa course de vitesse finalement avec
l'extrême droite pour lui reprendre
c'est le thème et ces termes pour autant
est-ce que vous comprenez cette colère
de la police qu'on a entendu notamment
hier lors de manifestations sur le
laxisme de la justice après
l'acquittement de huit personnes qui
avaient été mis en cause dans la taille
de policiers mais moi je comprends que
ceux qui souffrent de conditions de
travail indignes que ceux qui souffrent
d'un manque de reconnaissance salariale
sociale de la part de l'état puisse être
en colère mais le rôle des responsables
politiques ce n'est pas nécessairement
d'épouser toutes les colères c'est
d'apporter des solutions et c'est d'être
aussi garant de l'état de droit de la
république et du respect de la justice
la justice prend des décisions elles
doivent cette fois respectée alors autre
sujet qui fait débat ce sont les états
généraux de la laïcité ils ont été
lancés hier par marlène schiappa en
parallèle elle a annoncé le lancement
d'un fonds marianne pour la république à
fond de deux millions et demi d'euros
écouter marlène schiappa il vise à
financer des personnes et associations
qui vont porter des discours pour
promouvoir les valeurs de la république
et pour lutter contre les discours
séparatiste notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux et les plateformes en ligne
utile pour vous ce type d'initiative
c'est un bon moyen de lutter contre le
séparatisme coûté la laïcité c'est un
des plus beaux principes de notre
république
c'est fait pour apaiser elle est là pour
apaiser depuis 1905 pour rassembler pour
créer de la concorde
c'est parce qu'il ya la laïcité d'une
certaine façon dont nous pouvons
garantir la république nous ce point de
vue là moi je regrette que le
gouvernement de la république ne se
comporte pas comme tel mais que les
ministres
jouer tels des chroniqueurs de ses news
les apprentis sorciers de la laïcité
fracas c'est l'observatoire de la
laïcité de jean louis bianco et et
nicolas cadène qui faisait un travail de
terrain remarquable et ils ne se
comportent pas ne se met pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'est ce beau principe
tout simplement parce que il veut créer
la tension dans le pays créer là encore
une course
un concours lépine du discours anti
musulman un conte pour les vignes du
discours de brutalité de facturation du
discours séparatiste finalement avec
l'extrême droite
tout cela est très inquiétant est très
dangereux je crois que marlène schiappa
on est avec monsieur darmanin avec
d'autres l'illustration
en tout cas il y en a un qui est
particulièrement pessimiste sur l'avenir
d'emmanuel macron et sur l'avenir de la
france en général c'est philippe de
villiers regarder macron c'est fini
c'est la dernière illusion de cette
gauche caviar qui nous a fait croire à
la souveraineté européenne à la start up
nation à la mondialisation heureuse aux
chaînes de valeur globale à la religion
des flux depuis cinq ans les problèmes
qui étaient considérables devienne pas
soluble les murs porteurs de la france
sont en train de s'écrouler
la france est peut-être en train de
mourir
est-ce que vous l'observez cette france
qui bascule comme le dit philippe de
villiers est ce que ça vous inquiète
monsieur de villiers il vit depuis des
décennies avec des fantasmes des
obsessions ils voient des mosquées
souterraine cachée
il voit le déclin de la france bon ce
qui prouve une chose quand même c'est
que la stratégie de monsieur macron qui
consistait à aller baiser le mocassin de
monsieur de vie en permanence
avant même son élection à la présidence
de la république à aller seul apte et
l'extrême droite allait valider ses
discours allez légitimer sa présentant
eh bien on voit bien que tout ça à la
fin ne sert à rien avec cette stratégie
de course d à l'extrême droite mais
comme monsieur valls hier comme d'autres
comme monsieur sarkozy en son temps
qu'elle mène toujours à renforcer
l'extrême droite dans le débat politique
là il ya une nouvelle illustration et
moi les propos de monsieur de villiers
ne m'intéresse assez peu je crois que
c'est un un acteur politique
profondément réactionnaire profondément
islamophobes dont l'apa
pour moi n'a aucune valeur amo peut-être
sur votre famille politique pour
conclure avec cette volonté d'un
rassemblement d'une union avec les
écologistes ça va fonctionner selon vous
écoutez nous sommes aujourd'hui le 21
avril le 21 avril pour moi c'est le
souvenir du 21 avril 2002 quand l'ex
note pour la première fois que celles au
second tour la présidentielle depuis
elle forme de banalisation de
normalisation même de légitimation de
ses discours
la question qui nous est posée c'est
qu'est ce que en face de ses passions
tristes en phase de ce projet sombre en
face du racisme qu'est ce que nous
projetons nous la gauche et les
écologistes nous ont projeté un autre
imaginaire cette image in health à celui
de l'écologie sociale et populaire c'est
celui du partage des richesses c'est
celui par exemple de revenu universel
d'existence que nous défendons avec eux
avec benoît mans depuis 2000 17 pour
réussir pour mener cette bataille
culturelle sociale politique il faut
unir la gauche et les écologistes
c'est la condition de notre réussite
c'est la condition aussi de notre
capacité à créer un élan populaire pour
empêcher un duo duel entre monsieur
macro et madame le pen pour empêcher
finalement que ce pays ne sombre dans le
fascisme ou ne s'enferment durablement
dans l'ultralibéralisme
voilà donc nous avons une responsabilité
qui est historique il est important que
le 21 avril particulièrement nous
souvenions merci beaucoup
benjamin lucas va avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin dans la matinale de
rtl france le rappelle vous êtes
coordinateur national de génération
point s